this is the longest underwater pipe
on earth it stretches to the bottom of
the deepest place on the planet
where only a few people have ever
visited
and we're about to take you on an epic
journey to construct it
what materials would be suitable for the
task
what creatures would lurk around you
and at what point would constructing the
pipe
become unbearable
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you built a pipe to the bottom of the
mariana trench
there's a reason why only a few people
have ever made it to the bottom of the
mariana trench
let me tell you it's not the most
pleasant of trips
the deepest part of the trench called
the challenger deep
hits the mark at 11 kilometers
no light makes it that deep and
the temperature is just a few degrees
above freezing
if you were to dive down this deep with
or without a protective suit
the pressure would crush you it would
feel as if you had 100 elephants
standing on your head or as if you piled
five blue whales on your shoulders
that's what i call being under pressure
so how would we go about constructing a
pipe
in an environment where no human can
survive
[Music]
let's start from the beginning building
a pipe like this would require
a lot of planning preparation and
millions of dollars
you'd be aiming for a pipe that could
withstand pressure
1000 times greater than our normal
atmospheric pressure
what materials would even stand a chance
i could suggest steel since that's what
most water pipes are made of
it's durable and cost effective but
transporting 11 kilometers of pipe into
the ocean
as one piece would be next to impossible
you might be better off with
polyester or vinyl resin pipe
you could reinforce it with fiberglass
and assemble it under water
when you get to a depth that would crush
the fiberglass
you could add some steel well
that's the plan now let's see how it
would play out
as you descended 200 meters underwater
you'd leave the epipelagic zone and find
yourself
in the mesopelagic zone those
are the top two of five oceanic layers
your lungs would be getting compressed
as you descended
deeper and deeper but it would still be
doable at this point
as long as you were wearing a pressure
suit
it would be dark but you'd see twinkling
lights once your eyes adjusted to the
darkness
those would be the bioluminescent
animals that
call the mesopelagic zone their home
at 1 000 meters you'd entered the
bathypelagic zone of the ocean
and you'd better get into a submarine
because no
pressure suit would be able to keep you
from getting crushed now
from this point on underwater robots
would take over the construction
and maintenance the pipe itself
would need to be getting thicker so that
it could bear the
increasing water pressure and you'd
need a powerful flashlight because the
only visible light down there
is produced by creatures themselves
you'd descend deeper and hit the 4 000
meter mark
at this point you'd enter the abyssal
pelagic zone
now you'd truly see what dark looks like
no light at all can make it down to the
abyssopelagic territory
and the water temperature is near
freezing so
very few animals live here you'd be
lucky
to see a few tiny squid
[Music]
okay you're in the home stretch now in
the waters of the hadel pelagic zone
in the deepest the darkest the most
unexplored place on earth
i wouldn't recommend you descend all the
way down
at the bottom of the mariana trench the
pressure
is about 1100 atm
that's the feeling of 100 elephants
standing on your head building a pipe
here would be
challenging you'd need to send some very
durable robots to the bottom of the
trench because
these depths can implode even the
toughest of them
on top of enduring extremely high
pressure
they'd have to be able to withstand the
temperatures of just
above freezing nothing larger than three
centimeters can live in this dark
cold and absolutely hostile environment
so get cozy and let the robots finish
the pipe
and while you're up there controlling
the robots
watch out for those mags
but that's a story or another
what if before you go on to your next
hypothetical adventure
i want to show you something we're
really excited about this my friends
is the what if 100 book it's a beautiful
collection of your 100 favorite
scenarios
amazing artworks and additional facts
all in good old beautiful print and
paper
if you're like me and you enjoy an
inspiring read and some
time off the screen all the while
supporting one of your favorite youtube
channels
you might want to consider pre-ordering
this must-have encyclopedia of
imaginations
right now click the link below to learn
more
[Music]
you